a warm welcome for players as Hong
Kong's biggest sporting event Returns
the first Hong Kong sevens tournament
took place in the 70s now it's back
after a three-year pandemic hiatus
so having the Hong Kong sevens back is
first and foremost great relief it's
been a difficult three years for for us
in the Hong Kong Rugby Union and indeed
the rugby Community here in Hong Kong
has it has for so many other people but
to actually have live sports events back
in the city is fantastic but the
three-day event will look different this
year while quarantine requirements have
been removed for visitors to Hong Kong
face masks are mandatory and the stadium
capacity is capped at 85 percent
and there are limits on entering bars
and restaurants in the city but
officials are hopeful the rugby and
other international events this month
will help revive its economy will allow
more activities of the covert situation
is under control so that we can move
ahead to reconnect Hong Kong with the
world
authorities say the city is looking to
host
events next
Hong Kong is back to normal and we are
ready to welcome more International
visitors Hong Kong is the great city of
life so we look forward to your visit
strict covid-19 restrictions took a toll
on the city's economy
in three years almost 300 travel
agencies have shut down due to the lack
of visitors most of the country is the
open up I mean tourists have a choice
and then under this situations Hong Kong
will just not not be on their list the
city's economy has also been impacted by
an exodus of residents who feared the
Crackdown on dissent and the growing
influence of Beijing in the city's
political and legal systems major events
like this have long contributed to Hong
Kong's reputation as a thriving
international business Hub and an
attractive place for people to live and
visit while this year's tournament will
be different from years past some are
just pleased the event is back
we've had a bit of a Hiatus obviously
over the last three years which has been
difficult for everyone and I think
people are kind of relieved that the
sevens might spark a little bit of a
return to Hong Kong being that City that
everyone loves for a city that has
undergone so much change in recent years
the return of the sevens is an exciting
moment
Jessica Washington Al Jazeera